in all biological organisms there's
something referred to as the biological
imperative the biological imperative
can't be found by biologists there's no
place I say oh here it is in the cell
but what it represents is the drive to
survive when we start to feel that our
life is threatened it's not a conscious
at first it's a gut feeling it's
visceral something in my gut says
something's not right this is the
biological imperative looking at your
potential future in the world that
you're living in and what we really have
to recognize is that people are feeling
it in their gut the world is not right
it's not right I go well this is
wonderful because this is a feedback
system that's saying the world in which
you live is not in harmony with you and
therefore what it really means is that
we have to change how we influence the
world in our own way and it says that if
we start to change and send out love
instead of just receiving fear that the
love we send out has two two aspects yes
there's an external consequence of love
it influences everyone and everything
around me there's a profoundly different
chemistry if I have a thought of love
coming into my body would you can feel
when you're in love you can feel it yes
your cells are bathing in chemistry of
love but when you have fear it's a
different chemical response it gets you
girded up for response protection
Walling you off from the outside I don't
want that thing to come in and take care
of my inside and I say well what's the
relevance and the answer is very simple
the chemistry released by the brain and
fear shuts down the growth mechanism of
the body shuts down the maintenance of
the body to conserve energy and the
biggest thing is there's only one
consequence and that is disease and
illness and it turns out one percent of
disease on this planet is connected to
genetics ninety percent of disease or
more is lifestyle and the psychology of
love and fear ninety percent and says be
in love and your body will be maintained
and your immune system will be at Peak
Performance be in fear and the game is
over need motivation what's the top 10
will believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Bruce Lipton and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two reprogram your brain the
brain is a computer that's a clear fact
and it has the same functions and and
systems as our silicon conventional
computer that people is watching right
now and so here's the Insight I get a
brand new computer I got out of the
store and I push start and it boots up
what does that mean the screen lights up
I say oh great got a brand new computer
let's do a drawing let's do a story a
spreadsheet and I say no I can't do it I
say why not you got a brand new computer
you say not until I put programs in the
computer can I use that computer
and so I say oh and then after I got the
programs and then I can type and I can
interface the computer but I without a
program I can't do anything the human
brain as a computer gets programmed
starting in the last trimester of
pregnancy through age seven because the
brain function is not high enough for
Consciousness most of the time it's a
little lower and I say that's what we
said Theta hypnosis I say why is it
relevant the answer is very important
how many rules must a child learn to be
a member of a family and a member of a
community there's thousands of rules to
be of you know a person in the community
like a an infant can't read the book I
go no the infant brain is actually like
a video recorder it watches the mother
it watches the Father the siblings it
watches the community downloads their
behavior those are the programs
after age seven a child then can work
the computer and do what it wants okay
so I basically say so it started in
utero this is how uh um a mother can
play music uh through her abdominal wall
you know put the speaker there uh and
repeat that music and guess what when
the baby's born she plays that music the
baby instantly knows that music or the
father talks to the baby through the
abdominal wall uh and repeats this and
when the baby is born the moment the
father says something the baby will know
which one the father is because it
already memorized this stuff it
memorizes what the mother eats ah
because of the nutrition coming through
I say how does all this work simple we
talk about the blood is the culture
medium with the chemistry that
determines the genetics and I go so why
is it real if I say then whose blood is
the fetus using in development I go the
mothers so I guess so why is that
irrelevant well if she's having an
emotional response that's chemistry and
I said she's feeling that emotion
whether it's wonderful love or fear and
I go so why is it relevant that blood
with the same chemistry of the mother is
going into the fetus I go why is that
rub it the fetus feels what the mother
feels that the mother is under stress
and the fetus is getting an experience
that life is very difficult up there if
the mother is feeling love and support
and everything then the life is easy for
the fetus it started learning in the
last trimester
but then for the next seven years it
does the same and I go so why is it
relevant I go
once I get past age seven my
Consciousness can type on the keyboard
so I can program what I want and then
here comes the monkey wrench and the
monkey wrench is this the conscious mind
which types can think and you go so what
I go thinking is inside
you know if I ask you Jennifer I say uh
tell me what you're doing uh you know on
Tuesday yeah and right away you can tell
me but you'd have to think oh Tuesday
what am I doing I do that I say what's
the point
the conscious mind when thinking stops
looking out at the world and the
conscious mind looks inside so what if
you're driving your car and you're
driving down the street and all of a
sudden you have a thought and I say
conscious mind just not not looking out
anymore I said oh my God I'm gonna crash
the car because of my Consciousness is
inside
that's when the subconscious when the
conscious is thinking the subconscious
is autopilot and takes over like so why
is it relevant I go now science is
recognized 95 of the day is the average
person's amount of thinking okay so why
is it relevant well if a conscious mind
has your wishes and desires and
subconscious as your programs is your
life coming from your wishes and desires
I go up five percent
95 of your life is whatever the hell the
program you got from that seven years is
going to play and if you've got a
program that's not supporting you then
95 of the day your behavior will not
support you because that program doesn't
encourage you okay uh I always give the
audience the same story for 40 years now
okay and you know the story but I'll
tell your community because you have a
friend and you know your friend's
behavior and you happen to know your
friend's parent
and one day you see your friend has the
same behavior as their parents so you
really want to tell you're afraid to go
hey Bill you're just like your dad I
said back away from bill because I know
what Bill's going to say the first thing
you said how can you compare me to my
dad I'm nothing like my dad in the
audience laughs I go that's the most
profound story in the world right now
I'll tell you why
everybody else can see that bill behaves
like his dad who's the one that doesn't
see it Bill how the hell
if that's go with the control and while
he's thinking the behavior is playing
but because he's not even looking out at
his own behavior he doesn't even see his
own behavior yes so uh in his mind no
I'm not like my identical but everybody
else can see you behave like you're dead
you're the only one that can't see it
and I go so why is it relevant and the
answer is simply this we are all built
we all have beliefs wishes and desires
and then we have to say how come I'm not
manifesting the world I want how come
I'm not as healthy as I want to be how
come not creating the life I want if my
mind is the Creator and I go it is a
Creator but then I tell you which mind
are you operating from
and 95 of the day you're not operating
from conscious wishes and desires 95 a
day the subconscious programs are
automatically playing like what if those
programs are not any good I go
well you won't see it they'll just be
playing you know what you'll see the
result so I very simply I wake up in the
morning with conscious mind today I'm
gonna go find love today I'm gonna get
healthy today I'm gonna get the best job
and then at five o'clock you'll come
home and go uh didn't happen it didn't
happen and I go then what does that
person think because they're like Bill
they go oh everything's against me the
universe against me
this person is responsible that person
is responsible for not letting me get my
wishes and desires I go no all day long
you were shooting yourself in the foot
with your own behavior and you didn't
even know where the gun was coming from
it was in your own hand and I say so why
is irrelevant we have been programmed to
believe that when it doesn't work we are
victims of the outside when the truth is
no 95 percent of the day we were playing
programs that did not support us and as
a result the end of the day we didn't
get that support but we didn't see it
why subconscious was below Consciousness
was controlling your life your conscious
mind is I'm going to be healthy I'm
going to fall in love and I go that's
great but that's five percent of the day
yeah but 95 I go I'm coming from a
different program and so when you look
at your life and this is a beautiful
part you can say what are my programs I
just want to help people right away I'll
tell you what your programs are and you
say well how do I know I was being
programmed before I was born I was
programmed from zero to one can you tell
me what program you got when you were
zero no you didn't tell the program you
got a one no can you tell me the program
at two no about three you might say oh I
remember some things but I say you've
been essentially programmed with no
awareness of the program so you didn't
even see the program and now I say so
what is your program you go
I wasn't there now I give you the answer
and you're ready 95 of your life comes
from the program your life is a printout
of your program look at your life right
now and I'm going to tell you this very
simple the things you like that come
into your life they come in because you
have a program to bring them in yeah the
things you want Health relationship good
job your struggle you're working hard
you're putting a lot of effort in I'm
gonna make it happen I'm sweating I'm
going to work hard
why you're working so hard and the
answer is simply this your own program
doesn't support that you're trying to
override the 95 of the day that that
negative program is playing with five
percent effort going oh I want it to be
successful I go yeah and 95 of the day
you got what are you get from your
parent not smart enough not deserving
not good enough not lovable these are
things that we've downloaded in the
first seven years
and very interesting fact is this for
400 years the Jesuits have told their
followers the absolute truth and nobody
understood what they were talking about
I go what do you mean they would say and
this is a fact for 400 years they would
say give me a child until it is seven
and I will show you the man
what the hell does that mean the answer
is just as I said science has said the
first seven years you're in Theta
program
that's where you're learning then I said
but what about the rest you'll have to
go 95 of the rest of your life program
so if I can control the first seven
years I control the rest and that's what
they said give me a child until seven I
will show you the man meaning if you let
me do the first seven years of
programming I will tell you how that
child's life is going to work out rule
number three lead a healthy lifestyle
less than one percent of diseases
connected to genetics over 90 percent of
illness on this planet is all due to
stress and lifestyle and I say why is it
relevant because if we understood this
and ninety percent of illness would
disappear from this planet essentially
instantaneously uh so we have to make an
understanding of how do they connect
with each other okay so basically the
understanding is this
cells have to adjust their biology for
an environment so as the environment
changes cells have to change their
biology
and the significance about that as we
mentioned very briefly is that the genes
respond to the chemistry of the blood I
go
why because the chemistry of the blood
comes from the brain I go yeah but what
chemistry comes from the brain they go
it's based on the picture held in our
mind the brain translates our pictures
into complementary chemistry so for
example the if you open your eyes and
you see someone you love the brain
translates love into wonderful healthy
chemistry a dopamine for the great
pleasure oxytocin to bond with your
lover growth hormone which this function
is exactly that I go so why is a realm I
said well people fall in love they're
happy they're excited and they're
healthy because the chemistry that comes
from a picture of Love is a chemistry
that enhances the Vitality of the cells
in contrast though if I open my eyes and
I see something that scares me I say no
love chemistry is coming out of this
brain fear chemistry comes out and I go
what is fear chemistry related to and
it's simply related to an ancient
history uh fear means we were running
away from a saber-toothed tiger back in
those days I'm not gonna say what does
Fear represent
something is chasing you something's
interfering with you something's
threatening and fear uh and stress can
come about
I'll give you a simple definition of
what stresses anything that gets in the
way of your destination whatever your
destination is if something gets in the
way of that destination it provokes
stress okay and I guess so what's
relevant about this I say let's go back
and understand what the stress response
was all about and that was originally
run away from that saber-toothed tiger I
go what do you mean run away I go well
you want to save your life you better
start running immune's arms and legs and
start running and I go oh so in a state
of fear you want to use your arms and
legs I go yeah you know you hit them
with your pancreas you know the lion
doesn't care about that but if you run
away You're Gonna Make it and I go so
here's the storyline
the arms and legs are what protect you
and I say and to use them they need
blood because blood is where energy is
okay now I'm going to give you a
statement out of a physiology book and
then explain it very simply in a
statement is this when uh when a
person's in stress the blood is
preferentially sent to the arms and legs
okay yeah when I'm in stress more blood
is going in my arms and legs like I said
preferentially where was it before
I go it was in the gut I say well what's
the function of the gut
maintenance of the body fixing cleaning
repairing it takes care of Maintenance
of the body I say I say so why is it
relevant I said if you're running from a
saber-toothed tiger uh maintenance of
body is not necessary at this moment
Escape is necessary because if you don't
escape then the body is nourishment for
a tiger so uh the issue about is this
when stress hormones are released into
the system they cause the blood vessels
in the gut to squeeze shut
I go why is that because then it pushes
the blood preferentially to the arms and
legs people feel that when those blood
vessels are squeezing like this it's
called butterflies in the stomach they
feel a little queasy I go what is that
that's the closing of the blood vessels
shunting the blood off you can feel it
okay so I say oh so being chased by a
tiger I shut down the growth and
maintenance of my body to use the energy
to run away from the tiger okay
number two the immune system uses
tremendous amount of energy I go wait a
minute I said well if you've ever really
been sick you didn't even have the
energy to get out of bed okay so if the
immune system is really engaged you're
using a lot of energy and I go well the
immune system is protecting me from an
internal threat bacterial infection okay
so now I give you this scenario you're
being chased by a saber-toothed tiger
and you have a bacterial infection
how would you split the energy between
repairing the uh the infection or
escaping the tiger I hope everyone
understands how will the bacterial
infection why if the tiger catches you
the bacteria no longer is your problem
at that moment so uh basically then it
says this
when we are under a stress from an
outside threat uh the stress hormone
shut off the immune system to conserve
energy to escape the threat
and then I go wow what does that mean I
said well uh it doesn't you don't
activate the immune system because
um you need all the energy to run away
and I go well this is very critical for
a very important reason and I say well
why is it critical and I say well you've
shut down the immune system and a matter
of fact it's the stress hormones are so
effective at stress shutting down the
immune system
that when a person is going to receive
an organ transplant hard lungs or
whatever they give the recipient of
those organs stress hormones before the
operation but why because it prevents
the immune system from rejecting the
foreign organ right away it inhibits the
immune system so stress hormones are
used therapeutically to shut off the
immune system so I said what's the
consequence of this I say well you shut
down the growth of Maintenance about it
and you shut down the immune system yeah
but it's hey if you escape the tiger
it's 10 minutes you know if you escape
in 10 minutes no more threat and I go
then what oh you return back into growth
again okay so I go so why is this Robin
I said well that was a long time ago
when the only stress was a damn Tiger
but today people have stressed 24 7 365
stress every day and it's dripping
stress hormones into them I say well
what's it doing I said well a couple of
things I just mentioned it's interfering
with the growth and maintenance of the
body which has to be maintained uh and I
said well what's the consequence of that
I said it's a breakdown of the system so
prolonged stress causes a breakdown of
the of the system okay number two it
inhibits the immune system so you're
more open to infections and threats from
the outside so now not only have I
weakened myself now I've made myself
more open for infection because immune
system isn't working and then I'm going
to add the last one because I called the
last one adding the insult to the injury
well you just injured yourself you're
not maintaining your body you're not
using an immune system like what else I
go
when you're in a fight or flight
situation thinking is not a good thing I
go what do you mean thinking is slow
it's a very slow process I go so what
happens I say when the stress hormones
come into the into the body they also
squeeze the blood vessels shut in the
forebrain Consciousness I said so why
would it do that I say because it pushes
the blood to the hind brain where reflex
and reactions are taken care of so Allah
say you're driving a car and it starts
to go out of control guess what you're
not thinking then instantly your
Consciousness is shut off you're just
reflexively with the wheel and the
brakes the pedals whatever you know no
thinking I go oh
so then when we're under stress we are
less intelligent I go yes
and I go why is that relevant because
the fears that are in this world are
always compromising us to the extent
that the health care crisis is global
everywhere okay the amount of money you
spend on health care doesn't mean
anything is better the US spends the
most money on health care and Scott's
the worst health statistics of any other
country and you know in the Progressive
West I go why is that relevant I say
money didn't make us any healthier the
problem we have is not the immune system
the problem we have is stress and if you
eliminate the stress then the immune
system everything comes back to order
again and I go so what what's the issue
I say the health care crisis today has
virtually nothing to do with genes one
percent of illness that's probably about
the most 99 obviously is coming from
other where's illness coming from and
the answer is uh stress and lifestyle
rule number four eliminate threats the
stress is what is to to prepare you for
for a threat stress says there's
something threatening you and I say well
if I'm preparing for a stress that's
what we just mentioned I say if I'm not
threatened
I'm free to go outside and do anything I
want if I feel threatened I'm going to
wall myself off to protect myself put
all the goggles on the face mask and do
all our now I'm gonna be inside here and
I go you can't survive inside I'll give
a simple example when I was young we had
air raid drills in the U.S because we
thought the Russians were going to bomb
us so we built bomb shelters so I'll
give you a very simple story a city a
community is in a growth is a beautiful
day out the businesses are working the
kids are in school so this community is
is growing and doing well an air raid
siren goes off what does everybody do
they stop work where do they go they go
under the ground into the air raid
shelter I say them well I said well
nothing's happening now everything's
shut down okay like oh yeah and I say
then what I say well in 10 or 15 minutes
all clear
we get out of the bomb shelter everybody
goes back to work so it was like a you
know half hour Interruption during the
day where we were growing then we spent
a half hour in protection and then we
came out of protection and went back to
work again everything was Pro no problem
here's the problem
the air raid siren goes off you go into
the bomb shelter and there is no all
clear
I said what does that mean I said well
you can't come out of the bomb shelter I
said until what I said you can't come
out until it's all clear I said when's
it all clear so it's not getting all
clear I said how long can I live in the
bomb shelter I see not very long why how
much food did you put in there how much
water do you have in your bomb shelter
and the point is you'll use up those
resources and if you don't come out you
will die in the bomb shelter when we're
in stress we go into the bomb shelter
psychologically WE wall ourselves off
we're safe inside here and I say how
long can you survive inside the bomb
shelter I say a short period of time was
no big deal
but as you extend the time my life
becomes threatened and this covet crap
is going around and extending the fear
on and on and on again we're having a
second Spike I go
big deal I mean normal right why have a
predictable how come I have a second
Spike I said if you take the susceptible
people and you move them into a
quarantine so they're not exposed to the
virus and they're healthy in their room
but I say then you say quarantine over
and you come out I go did the virus go
away no that's still there are you still
susceptible of course you are you didn't
get any immune reaction in the bomb
shelter over there I say so what do you
think would happen if you let that group
of people you put away back out I go
they'll get infected just like the first
group of people and guess what it's
called a spike I go of course it's a
spike you took them out of the program
you put them back into the show they get
to see and then you say the second Spike
I go did you not expect a second Spike
and what reason why would there not be a
second Spike there you didn't lose the
virus you didn't gain any immune to some
you know precaution against it you just
opened up the next population yeah here
we are in the second Spike of course
that's exactly what would happen if you
take the population and put it away and
then think well okay now they can come
back out I said you didn't change
anything they're just out now the second
Spike so so all of this stuff and I go
so you want to know what I believe the
biggest problem the whole thing is
because I see it as a manipulation of
information and that is this
people have power when they're in a
community
people have no power when there is no
community and the covid system broke
Community all over the world at once
everybody went to their room
I go and what power do you have I say
absolutely no power people lost all the
power in the world except for those that
were manipulating what was going on
outside of that room and that was a way
of disempowering an entire damn
population of this planet with the fear
they said go hide in your room because
you can't gather together you can't have
an opinion together no you can stay in
your room and you stay in your room and
all of a sudden oh my God that's the
biggest problem in the whole world
you've isolated people and when you've
done that you've removed their ability
to have power also to make sure you're
actually taking action after a while to
watch video I
free work
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five change your
perception perception can rewrite the
genetic code when you're under stress
you will rewrite your genes it's built
into every one of your cells you have
genetic engineering genes the function
of these genes is if you find stress
that the body cannot seem to get out of
the body will make an effort to change
its structure to get out of the problem
and of course the issue is this what if
your perception wasn't real and you
change your genes now you're in deep
doo-doo
and we now find a very important fact
95 percent of cancer has no genetic
linkage
95 of cancer is a response of the
individual cells to their experiencing
life
and if you change your experiences you
can change the presence of that cancer
that's how it works rule number six
remove stress from your life why does
stress cause so much disease I'll tell
you why
stress you're running away from that
saber-toothed tiger whatever's
threatening you and I say what is stress
anything that gets in the way of where
you want to go is a stressor I say so
why is that relevant I go because that's
like in the mind the Sabertooth tiger
and you want to run that's what fight or
flight and I said but you use your arms
and legs I go yeah but that I need the
energy I said the blood carries the
energy so I say so what when the stress
hormones come into the body you want the
body to put the blood into the arms and
legs because you're going to have to run
that's what fear and stress is about
okay so what do you mean put isn't it in
the arms of life like oh yeah but most
of the blood is in your gut I say what's
the gut all the organs of Maintenance
take care of your health fix the blood
you know aerate clean all that stuff I
go yeah but when you're in stress I
don't need to take care of myself I got
to run away from the tiger so stress
hormones number one shut off the blood
vessels in the gut and I said that's
like butterflies in the stomach when you
feel that fear that's the stress
hormones causing the blood vessels
squeeze I said so why would you do that
because then the blood is pushed to the
arms and legs that's where most of the
energy is needed that's number one so
you compromise Health just by having
stress hormones because you're shutting
it off the maintenance but number two
the immune system uses a lot of energy
that's why when people are sick
sometimes they can't even get out of bed
I say so if I'm being chased by a
saber-toothed tiger and I got a
bacterial infection how do I want to you
know split the energy and I go the hell
with a bacterial infection that
saber-toothed tiger catches you bacteria
is not your problem anymore so guess
what stress hormones by function shut
down the immune system and I go and it's
so effective that when doctors want to
transplant a foreign organ into a
recipient and they don't want the
recipient's immune system to reject the
foreign organ before they do the
transfer they give the recipient stress
hormones to shut off the immune system
so it doesn't reject the foreign organ I
say this stress hormones are so
effective at shutting it off they use it
therapeutically to shut it off and I go
why is it relevant because our entire
world is in such stress all the time
that they're dripping stress hormones
and I say what are they doing they're
shutting off the growth and maintenance
of the body they're shutting down the
immune system I say net result illness
and death from stress and that is why up
to 90 percent of illness comes from
stress because the chemistry of [ __ ] of
stress redirects your energy to run not
to be conscious and aware and healthy
rule number seven take care of yourself
take care of yourself I say what you
mean first of all take care of your
system it will manage this virus without
killing you but first of all you have to
make sure your blood has proper
nutrition you need to be healthy in a
system and our diet is so compromised
within oh yeah food and garbage food
that I have to tell people you've got to
go back and eat natural you have to go
back and eat organic because industrial
Farm stuff is filled with chemistry that
is is causing you more problems
number two take vitamins and supplements
why especially vitamin C and vitamin D
these enhance the immune system lots of
vitamin C Way Beyond whatever
relationship you met Linus Pauling yes
you know and it's interesting because I
lectured at his uh Institute when I was
at Stanford wow and it was interesting
because the science has revealed that
massive doses I take two grams of
vitamin C every morning high five
an irrelevance about that is I'm also
you know I'm what am I trying to do
de-stressing I'm not stressed I live in
another world I walk out the door I
don't live in that world of the people
around me they're the ones that are
stressed I'm like I'm not stressed I'm
okay I'm 76 am I afraid because I'm old
[ __ ] it's oh BS belief system excuse
me uh uh that um I'm not afraid to go
outside
I I eat well I take vitamins and
supplements hey
do work exercise something to keep the
body moving because that enhances the
Vitality of the circulatory system which
is delivering immune function so eat
well vitamin supplements you exercise
and number four most important do not
put the fear in your head
because the function of the mind is to
manifest whatever you believe and if you
start to believe in the fear then the
function of the mind is to manifest that
fear and that's why the whole idea is
shut off the damn TV and don't listen to
these people because they are
disempowering you
with fear
and fear is where you lost your power
because once you do fear as you shut
yourself off and you can't shut yourself
off we are connected to a world you
can't live in a bubble you'll die
and the idea is if you buy the fear you
are putting up walls around you because
you want to protect I'm protecting here
I say walls are the opposite of growth
growth you have to open yourself up
things in okay and uh and fear as you
shut everything down rule number eight
do not lose your energy there's
something called resonance when
something vibrates at the same vibration
they enhance their power so two
instruments are playing at the same
vibration that vibration is more
Amplified okay uh but here's the point
why does a patient come to a doctor and
the answer is because we have been
programmed to believe that's our source
of healing they never said what the
doctor had to do when you were a kid oh
you're sick we go to the doctor remember
nobody told you what a doctor would do
what did you learn that the doctor
provides whatever it is so we give up
power over our life because that doctor
is a professional what the hell do I
know I'm just as an average person so
when it comes to a truth which is my
conscious and subconscious mind when it
comes to a truth I give up power to the
doctor
so if the doctor has got a lot of energy
and everything is energy that's a whole
different I wish we had another hour I'd
talk about that but uh the illusion of
matter that that's uh that's we look
like everything is physical and quantum
physics as a scientist says no
everything is energy so I say when a
person who is an energy source goes to a
doctor who is an energy source the
healing comes from the doctor having a
higher energy a higher more powerful
energy so when I walk into the doctor's
office just walking into the doctor's
office all of a sudden I feel a
different energy because that's the
person that knows and I don't and I say
so why is a romance if a doctor goes in
not having a good day and chiropractors
know this they they can practice for
years and then sometimes they go in and
the whole day is crappy adjustments and
it's like it's not working well I say
well to forget how to do an adjustment
you've been doing it 30 years no they
came in with their own mind nothing in
harmony whether they had a fight with
their spouse or their financial issues
like oh why is it relevant the person
that came in for the healing came in for
the extra energy that the Healer was
going to give them
but if the Healer themselves have broken
energy because of the stresses and
there's all that when the patient comes
in the doctor has no powers very much
and that's why they realize geez my
adjustments didn't work and I've been
doing it all these years I go you didn't
forget how to do adjustment but when
you're touching somebody that's called
Hands-On healing
and if you're putting in energy that's
less than the energy of the patient yeah
then the energy of the patient comes
down instead of going up
physician heal thyself meaning before
you go in there and deal with the
patient they came in for your energy and
if your energy is not up to the higher
level then you can't boost their energy
you can only boost it if your energy is
higher and so the physician the Healer
the nurse more important because they're
even the ones I'm more importantly or
the more dialogue connected to the
patient than than a lot of Physicians
who hardly even notice what's going on
but it's nurses a lot and the age that
are doing a lot of the healing why
they have the energy they spend more
entanglement time sure and and therefore
that's really interesting so what is
healing I say raising the energy the
vibration energy is life no energy death
high energy a lot of life is the
physician the Healer the nurses the
attendant are they offering more energy
than the patient has if they do then
you're lifting the health of that
patient rule number nine discover your
spirituality I'll leave with this
because it's so profoundly important in
our world today and that is this
apparently presumably one of the last
things Jesus said when in the
crucifixion was father forgive them they
know not what they do
and I go we have to recognize that every
human
is is a spiritual entity but also a
program
and we have to recognize that they are
not their program that's been foist upon
them
and that somebody has a bad program and
we get into uh like this I say you have
to learn to forgive them because they
themselves like Bill Bill didn't know
he's behaving like his dad they don't
know it either and so the idea is that
word that that phrase applies to each
one of us to move into the future and
that is recognize that everyone is a
spiritual entity but a lot of people
have some bad programs does that make
them a bad person I go it makes a bad
program for sure do I have to hang
around with them because they got bad
programs say no but do I have to hate
them no
because they don't even know what the
hell they're doing and all of a sudden
it says this forgiveness
of people doesn't mean you have to be
with them you know they want to play
that program fine you do it over there
I'm over here but you have to recognize
is it them or their program
and then when you recognize this then
that's where that quote comes important
forgive them they don't Bill didn't know
what the hell he was doing and we are
all built
angle number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is learn to
adapt by the way we are polluting the
atmosphere and destroying the ecosystem
we are aggravating climate change we're
exacerbating climate change so we are
indeed involved and the significance
about it is this climate changes our
most immediate problem on this planet of
course you've seen the pictures of
seawater Rising with melting ice caps
and thinking that's where the big
problem comes from and yet on a positive
note let us recognize a simple fact
human civilization is the most adaptable
of all organisms on this planet the
question we ask now is will we learn to
adapt when climate change is a
continuous process and we cannot depend
on growing food to support the
population
if you change the picture in your mind
you change the chemistry you change the
Fate so I'll give an example
if I have a picture of Love in My Mind
the brain releases complementary
chemistry dopamine pleasure oxytocin
bond with your loved one growth hormone
which does exactly what it says it
enhances your growth and that's why when
people fall in love the chemistry of the
brain going into the blood the culture
medium enhances Vitality people glow
when they fall in love people are
healthy when they fall in love it's not
an accident it's the chemistry of your
culture media but now I say but wait
what if I have a picture of fear I go oh
well love chemistry doesn't come out
when fear is in the picture the brain
releases stress hormones and factors
that affect the immune system and growth
of the system and I go oh my goodness I
say why is it relevant changing my
thought changes my chemistry the
chemistry adjusts my biology so if I can
control my thoughts I can control the
chemistry and therefore I control the
biology that takes me to empowerment
Mastery after being programmed by
medicine and biology all these years
that you're just a victim of your genes
that's 100 false genes cannot turn on
and off by themselves they're controlled
by the signals of the environment which
are then controlled by the brain and the
Consciousness and all of a sudden it
says yeah but I control those things I
go yes you do and as a result you have
power
to heal yourself and create what you
want on this planet the belief that
James turned on and off is taking power
away from the individual because if the
genes were turning on and off and I did
not control them then by definition I am
a victim of which genes did I get from
my family did cancer genes come in the
heart disease genes or diabetes and now
we recognize that in regard to disease
genes are responsible for less than 10
percent of disease in fact there are
indications that genes are only
responsible for one percent of disease
so all of a sudden it says well wait we
used to think genes cause disease but if
only a small percent of disease is
controlled by genes and where is the
disease coming from that is affecting
the world the answer is now we know from
epigenetics Consciousness lifestyle
belief systems these are the ultimate
controls of the gene we know that if
you've got a cancer Gene and that's what
you believe then you think I'm going to
get the cancer and then you get a Cancer
and you say the genes did it and now we
know no that there is no cancer Gene
there is not one gene that causes cancer
genes are correlated with cancer meaning
if your life is not in Harmony and you
have one of these genes you can activate
a cancer
50 percent of the women that have the
same brca1 gene never get the cancer the
point is very important having the gene
doesn't mean you've got cancer but
having the Gene and not living in
harmony not living in a healthy
lifestyle that causes the cancer
and so we have to help people take them
from the belief I'm a victim and give
them the science that no your
Consciousness is creating this life
experience in here your Consciousness is
controlling your genes in today's world
I love the phrase because it is funny
but it's true
fake it until you make it man you want
to be happy well you have to habituate
happy you have to say every day no
matter if you don't if you're not happy
I don't really care you have to tell
yourself I am happy I am happy you have
to repeat it ah habituation repetition
why I'm consciously repeating it every
day and look at my life my life really
sucks oh Bruce I am happy I am I'm
saying that I go well why are you saying
it because repetition is how the
subconscious mind learns I say why is
this relevant and here's the fun part
because after I've repeated it a number
of times the subconscious says okay I'm
happy as I've learned this I go why is
irrelevant that 95 of the day the
subconscious function is to make that
program real if my program is I am happy
the function of the mind is to make sure
I'm happy if the if the program says I'm
going to get cancer because I heard that
from somebody else then the function of
the mind is to make sure I get cancer
because that's the belief I'm more
working with
and if if it says I am a victim and I
can't get out of this
then the function of the mind is yep
look you see you I'm showing you you're
a victim and you can't get out of it
because I'm running a show you're a
victim cells in your body are not
connected to the outer environment but
they have to adjust themselves to that
outer environment and the relevance
about that well then how they know what
to do because
something has to tell them what the heck
is going on and so it turns out the
nervous system
interfaces the environment and then
sends signals to the cells to tell them
what's going on so the cells are
responding to the perceptions and
actions of the central nervous system
and I say why is that relevant because I
say it's an interpretation and so the
cells the simple point you got 50
trillion citizens and the conscious uh
the mind is a government yes and the
government talks to these cells now you
can have a bad leader who tells them
this is all crap it's all falling apart
things don't work and it's like they're
not going to be happy cells and it can
profoundly different you talk to
yourselves and tell them okay
everything's cool we're great
when there's a big you know in the U.S
an accident or you know big big problem
in some Community the president goes to
the community yes why does the president
go because it takes the attention of all
the other citizens of the of the states
focuses on the intention where that
president is so if there's an area where
there's a disaster the energy of all the
people are addressed to that area
because the president shows up there and
that's the leader so I'm saying the same
thing for yourselves you're sort of that
president in there and the point is when
you touch some part on your body your
conscious attention focuses on that part
of the body and intention is energy and
it's a healing energy when you're
sending a good message uh to that part
of the body so you touch it talk to it
and it sounds like oh crazy I go no you
are directly sending information to your
Consciousness to all the cells to focus
healing on this part in our mind we
start to realize that we're concerned
we're afraid we don't have enough I'm
not safe I'm not secure and I say oh
these thoughts I was talking about the
thoughts in your mind go in and control
your biology your genetics your
physiology and your health and I go yes
this is really true I said well how can
I tell you what your thoughts are in a
sense that can I read your thoughts and
I say yes you know I could put wires on
your head and it's called
electroencephalograph and I could read
your brain activity and I go oh great I
can see this brain activity I want to
tell you something that's profoundly
important
we were programmed to believe that our
thoughts are contained in our head that
if I have a thought it's just for me not
for anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now I want to tell you about a new
technology it's not
electroencephalograph it's called
magnetoencephalograph I say what's
unique about that I say read your brain
I say yeah but so does EEG I say yeah
but EEG put the wires on the head and
you get the electrical activity
conducted through the skin from the
brain and that's what I'm reading and I
said what's different about Meg
the probe is out here
and I said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head your thoughts are broadcast to the
field just like a radio broadcast I said
well what if I as an individual have a
thought that says let's have peace in
the world
and I broadcast out there in the street
and I say let's have peace and I look
around it's like where's the piece I
don't see the peace and here's what the
relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is Amplified each of us
has a small power
but if you put a thousand people of the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field I say your energies in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
I'll give you this most wonderful quote
I used it the other day in a lecture
from Albert Einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field so a definite definition the
field is the invisible energy right now
you're in a field there's cell phone
broadcast television television radio
broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field the
quote the field
is the soul governing agency of the
particle
particle is the material Realm
so what was Einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives and if
enough of us collectively have an energy
that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast the belief we change the world
I just want you to recognize as much as
I wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if I want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced that the war is
going to benefit them so that their
broadcasts say yes let's have a war
because I and my colleagues we're all
going to have a better result from that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga when you're in your postures
when you're in your process your mind is
sharing a thought not just in your head
but all around you so the whole idea
about this is we have to recognize we
are collectively creating reality with
our thoughts and if we want to change
reality it can change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking you get enough people to say
peace there will be peace instantly in
this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to give them the power to tell us
what we need
and Assad Fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and I really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field and
that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore what this world is looking
for at this moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough it will end Jesus told
his followers all the Miracles that I
can do you can do them but even better
than I can and you don't believe it and
that was the whole damn thing in a
nutshell if you don't believe it you
can't do it and I said well where's
belief come from mind I say and what
have you been programmed you can't do
and I said then you'll never be able to
do it
and this is the problem and and so we
talked about way number one you want to
change it hypnosis because that's the
original way things went in in the first
place and you're you know you that what
you said was true the evenings just say
I feel amazing I feel amazing to repeat
that the mind will will all of a sudden
change how you feel that's that's how it
doesn't Okay so I say number one
self-hypnosis number two after age seven
you still learn how to do new things
that become habits like you didn't learn
how to drive a car until until later
than seven but once you know how to
drive a car remember the first day you
got in it was like oh my God looking out
the windows checking the mirror watching
the gauges keeping your feet on the
pedals just correctly you know looking
paying all these attentions like and I
say today you've been driving for a
while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am I going to do when I get to the
store you're not even thinking about
driving why it's a habit okay I say well
how did you get that habit because
you're older than seven how'd you get it
I said repetition that's what makes a
habit practice you want to play an
instrument I'll hand you an instrument
yeah you didn't have any practice then
you're not going to be able to play it
and I say oh practice what is that
repetition
that's the second way the subconscious
learns repeating something over and over
and over again because that's called
habituation making a habit and I love it
the new age today thing is fake it till
you make it I go what the hell is that I
said you're not happy yeah most of us
have trouble being happy and I say but
what if every day all day long and you
can remember you say I am happy in spite
of the fact of what the hell is going on
you just say I am happy I am happy I am
happy I go why what's going on I say
repetition and it'll be a point where
you'll repeat it to the degree that the
subconscious which learns by repetition
will put in I am happy I said then
what's the consequence they said what's
the function of the Mind take that
program and manifest it now that it's in
there I am happy I wake up one morning
guess what I don't have to say I'm happy
it's automatic I'm already happy all day
long my program said that uh 95 is
coming from that habituation
you know repetition of the exact thing
you want not Future Vision as if you
have it now we'll put it in a program so
that's first seven years hypnosis after
seven years uh repetition habituation is
how you change it uh a sticky note
people put that stuff on a mirror or
someplace and they oh yeah those they
can go and I go that is not repetition
that's a suggestion a repetition is a
practice you have to repeat things
that's you practice an instrument you
practice driving a car you practice
doing these things and then it became
real okay so the first two things are uh
hypnosis second thing is repetition and
thirdly the most you know
effective is called Energy psychology
and I go what's energy psychology it's
called super learning you know so what
the hell is super learning I go maybe
you've seen somebody read a book
by picking up a book and just moving
their finger down the page just like
that just as fast as that
and guess what the subconscious mind the
super computer that it is has read every
word just by moving your finger down
around is read every word on that page
and a person using the super learning
technique and going to a bookstore open
up a book and five minutes later by
thumbing through each page Turn the Page
Turn the Page Turn the Page they can
read a whole book in five minutes that's
super learning I say if you can engage
that function
you can also use super learning to
create new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes it's like I go absolutely and
it's so important why because uh there's
an old phrase that's really critical
it's called necessity is the mother of
invention and I say what's happening
we're facing a mass extinction due to
human behavior that is compromising the
Web of Life humans are creating this
through our Behavior or culture I say
you want to survive this episode this
whole you know Extinction event well
then you have to create something
different you have to change Behavior
everything you do in your life you put
out energy for therefore start to review
what you're doing in your life because
if you're putting your energy into
things you cannot change in this world
that is exactly the same as writing a
check and just throwing away your money
to the outside because you get nothing
back from it so think about this very
interesting real quality that you have
this energy checkbook and every time you
use energy you have to say is the use of
this energy
going to enhance my life or is it just
wasted energy am I getting involved in a
in a political argument with people
where I'm going to use up all my energy
and will I have changed the world no
am I going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier and they're
not ready to do that I'd be wasting my
energy
so here's an interesting thought if I
gave you an energy checkbook and asked
you to write a check every time you had
to have a thought you would have to then
ask yourself is is this thought going to
enhance my life or is this thought going
to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go Beyond
Survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thoughts you put into the fear not only
are you just wasting your energy but as
in the biology belief these negative
thoughts these negative stresses
actually impair your immune system and
bring on disease itself how many people
may think well hold on a second so I can
take five minutes and I can totally
change my life and that's all I need and
I think that's a really a wonderful
possibility but the probability is this
are you going to hit the right statement
that is the one that you need to change
your life okay let's say someone's
overweight and they say in their mind I
I am you know a weight a number they
like I am 125 pounds and you're not
uh and I say uh so I want to change my
weight and I put a program in I'm going
to lose weight and I go about well wait
that extra poundage uh that might be due
to protection okay what do you mean I
say if I was as an as a young person was
abused then the Consciousness is if I'm
a heavy person they won't bother me
anymore and so the weight isn't due to
just eating food the weight was due to I
am safer being heavy than I am I say
well if you want to change your weight
you can talk about the weight all you
want but until you adjust the problem
from the the fear uh you know that I'm
going to be abused that's where the
problem came from it didn't come from
eating food over here so I said yeah
well you can change beliefs uh sometimes
I like to give a visual a matter of fact
I visualize a big spider web which has
like circles and then lines coming out
you know like a web okay and so there
are links as you go around there's also
anchors where the web is anchored at a
couple places and I go each belief is
like a link
and that spider weapon you can do one
link on another link on another link
that really change the spider web but if
you do a belief that is an anchor and
you change the anchor belief and that
anchor lets go
the web will collapse that's possible
the point is this sometimes a police
statement knocks out a link
but when you're really hit it just right
you knock out a support and when you
knock out a major support the whole web
collapses instead of just a link at a
time which could take it down but it's
much harder the thinking he's not that
much in our control the brain is
operating as I said 95 from the
subconscious
but how did you actually then get
results in a relatively short space of
time well the first thing how does a
subconscious learn and that's a very
critical thing uh the conscious mind can
learn from reading a book so you the
subconscious mind can read a self-help
book and you go wow that sounds really
great and then you find you read the
book but your life is still the same and
this turns out why and the answer is
because the subconscious mind is more of
a habit mind things that you repeat over
and over again so the reality is if you
can stay conscious
be present and when those negative
thoughts come in our head and
psychologists tell us 70 of the time the
thoughts that are going through our head
are negative and redundant so the same
negative thoughts are going through if
you could stop those thoughts if you
could hear them as they come through
like oh that's not going to work oh this
will never happen those kind of thoughts
if you can hear them and stop them
consciously say no uh change the belief
right there just give the more positive
thing as you repeat this more frequently
and you keep repeating it the
subconscious mind begins to learn so as
a habit if you stay conscious and you
have to work at it and here's why people
say well how come only five percent from
conscious mind 95 for from subconscious
because a conscious mind can think into
the future and think into the past and
solve problems then think about it
yourself most of the time you're
thinking about something well if you're
thinking you're using the conscious mind
well if you're using a conscious mind
for thinking then who's running the show
and the answer is when you're not paying
attention and you're thinking about what
I'm going to do tomorrow your
subconscious is running so I was a
scientist and as a scientist we don't
bring spirituality and mind into the
story it's all genes and cells and
molecules and all that and my research
uh on on stem cells uh revealed that
while I was teaching in medical school
that genes control life my research
revealed that it was the environment in
which the cells lived that control the
cells it was outside information coming
into the cells and I remember how
specifically in a moment of time that I
was working on trying to understand the
mechanics from a molecular point of view
how does an environmental signal control
biology and I was working not on the
genes I was working on the skin of the
cell the membrane and it was it was so
profound it's hard for me to even
describe it I'm working on the
understanding how does information from
from the environment control biology and
I had looked at the membrane for years
and I wrote a new definition of the
mechanism of the membrane
and I wrote this definition this is in
1985. it was about 2 am
and I wrote down the membrane is a
liquid Crystal
semiconductor with Gates and channels
when I wrote that down there was a pause
and I said I I just I read something
exactly like that and right next to my
first computer Macintosh was a book from
a simple book of understanding your
microprocessor and I opened it up and I
said somewhere and I open it right in
the introduction it said a chip
is a crystal semiconductor with Gates
and channels and I thought oh what a
coincidence they have the same
definition
and then in a couple of seconds I
started to say wait a minute
one for one the parts are exactly the
same I said oh oh my God the membrane is
a computer chip
and on the surface of the cellar like
Keys like on a typewriter and and I
started to realize oh my goodness the
environment is typing on the surface of
the cell information that went into the
cell and control the genetics and the
behavior and it was like oh oh this is
real exciting and I'm typing on my own
computer typing this information in and
then I realized I am outside of the
computer typing on the keyboard and the
information is coming up on the computer
then I said oh my God
this keyboard on the surface of your
cells has a number of keys that
represent a PIN number a personal
identification number and no two of you
have the same keys on that each of us
have a different pin number to get into
our own cells it's our personal identity
and these are the keys and I realized oh
my god well we've been focusing on these
what are called receptors as the source
of identity I realize no it's what's
activating what's typing is the identity
and then it hit me and said oh my God my
identity is not in the cell my identity
is a signal coming from the environment
typing in the keyboard and then I said
oh and the first thing that hit me was
I can't die I'm not even in here
and that instant the fear which all of
us have in our deepest bottom belief
system is a fear of more mortality
and when that moment of like I can't die
not as a devotional belief it had
nothing to do with that it was just a
mechanism I said oh my God I can't die
I tell you the same thing happened with
Savages me
tears started rolling down my face and
this Joy was an ache in my heart that
I've never experienced before I spent 40
years in my head that's how I became an
academician and a research scientist and
when this moment hit it was my heart
that blew open I referred to it as a
heart orgasm and
and that was the first time I
experienced my heart as a as an
essential part of my own conscious
existence and what happened was
I was overwhelmed first with the fact
that I was not spiritual at 1 59 a.m and
at 2 A.M I was 100 spiritual we have a
very close friend you know your friend's
behavior and you happen to know your
friend's parent and at some point you
see that your friend shares the same
behavior as their parent so you you know
you casually volunteer you go you know
Bill you're just like your dad and
that's when you have to back away from
bill because Bill's the first guy that
says how could you compare me to my dad
and everyone laughs because they're
familiar but I say no there's two very
profound points from that one story and
profound Point number one everybody else
can see that bill behaves like his dad
he got his programming from his dad it's
only Bill who doesn't see it and
profound Point number two we're all bill
because all of us got programming and
all of us operate with these programs
and we don't even see we're doing that
we even when told we're doing it will
deny that we do these behaviors because
we don't even see what we're doing
that's why it's called subconscious
below conscious when I first started
talking about it it was from an academic
conscious point of view this is what I
learned but my subconscious programs
were still exactly the same so well I
had this wonderful knowledge my life
still wasn't anything I wanted to to
brag about it because it wasn't and and
as you know that old gamer who would you
like to be and I could think of anybody
I'd rather be than me And yet when I
started to apply the new science and
rewrite the subconscious so it supported
me rather than the programs of
limitation or disempowerment that we get
from our parents and our community as
children which almost all of us get when
I put in the new programs all of a
sudden I started to find my goodness my
life completely turned around uh all
wonderful things started happening in my
life I was healthier I haven't been to a
doctor in 20 years I I don't need that I
don't take any of their drugs why
because most of the illness is just from
the stress of not living in Harmony and
when you learn to to get rid of the
limiting programs that we got as
children and put in programs that
support you guess what then all of a
sudden the place turns into heaven uh
and it's interesting to people I tell
people will you create your own life and
then they look around and go I don't
want responsibility for this but I say
well you didn't know you were creating
with these unconscious beliefs and and
yet then I tell people especially people
that have fallen in love and people have
fallen head over heels in love I said go
back to that time when you first fell in
love let me ask you a question were you
healthy and oh yeah I was I was healthy
as anything I said you have energy I
said oh I had so much energy made love
for days in a row without even eating
and I go yeah and I go uh and how was
life for you it was so exciting I
couldn't wait for the next day so I said
in this little period that you you know
that I refer to as a honeymoon I say
wasn't life like heaven on Earth and
they go well yeah and I go you know that
was not an accident that was an actual
creation and you say but what was
different that made life uh uh so heaven
on Earth during love and the answer is
because you become very self-conscious
of yourself you don't rely on the habits
the day before you meet this person
you're going to go on a date I say
especially the women I say how long did
it take to get dressed and they say well
it was 15 minutes and I was out of the
house and then I say now tonight you're
going to go on a date with this person
who has just rocked your world and I
said how long does it take you to get
dressed it's like my God it may take an
hour or two and I said yesterday 15
minutes today an hour or two what's the
difference yesterday I got dressed by
habit because I get dressed every day
but tonight I am looking in the mirror
meaning I am self-conscious I am making
sure that I represent myself to be the
fully the best individual I can be and
when both parties are not relying on the
habit and both of them are saying I'm
creating the best I can be they're
living in the moment of them now they're
being very mindful they're being very
present and guess what
heaven on Earth is created well how do
you change the subconscious mind say how
did it learn in the first place
I say what was the first one I say Theta
seven years brain was functioning lower
vibration than Consciousness you have to
slow down the brain to a much slower
vibration then it goes into the
subconscious mind that's why um
hypnotherapists in the old days they had
a watch and they would swing it back and
forth so the watch would swing and they
would tell the person you're getting
sleepy you're getting tired and the
reason they say that is because that
shuts down the conscious vibration and
the next vibration is Theta which is
hypnosis so to get you into hypnosis
first I have to get your conscious brain
to stop and then in hypnosis State Theta
the vibration Theta then whatever is
coming from the outside is not going
into my conscious mind whatever I see on
the outside is going into my
subconscious program
so if you want to change the
subconscious you have to talk to the
subconscious they go how you do that
well number one hypnosis and I go oh
well I need to see the hypnotherapist I
go no this is the cool part I say why I
said we have different vibrations the
lowest vibration is Delta is sleep the
next higher vibration is Theta hypnosis
imagination the next higher vibration is
Alpha calm Consciousness and the next
higher vibration is called beta which is
like School room like what we're doing
here Consciousness okay I go so why is
it rub I said when you're asleep you're
at the lowest and when you start to wake
up you go up first to Theta and that's
like in the morning where you're half
awake and half asleep and and then I
said but then when you're awake you're
an alpha now you're in Consciousness and
then when you go to work you're in beta
which is like the work in Consciousness
but when you come home it reverses so I
come home from work I'm in beta but I
relax oh the Consciousness vibration
slows down the alpha and here's the fact
the moment that the vibrations get a
little lower than Alpha Consciousness is
now shut off for the night you're
sleeping yeah but there's a period of
time after Alpha shuts off before it
reaches Delta the lowest one there's a
period of time of theta I go y's
irrelevant I said you put earphones on
and the moment and you play a program of
what of what you want a self-help
program of have a mega relationship be
healthy do a job whatever you get the
program self-help program I say you put
it on on a CD player let's say and you
put the earphones on and while you're
still awake just before you go to sleep
you can hear what's going on but the
moment you fall asleep conscious Minds
shut off but guess what Theta is on the
work is getting done right right you're
getting a self-hypnosis with the
earphones so whatever the you didn't
hear it you were sleeping the
subconscious mind was hearing it and
when you repeat that that's how you put
a new program in so that's number one
self-hypnosis I was cloning stem cells
back in 1967. 40 years ago and the
significance was while I was doing this
research I was also teaching medical
students so I was teaching medical
students the foundation of how cells
work the conventional story out of the
textbook genes control life what we call
the genetic determinism the belief that
genes control your traits Behavior your
physical characteristics Etc and what my
research revealed when I was studying
the stem cells was this very profound I
put one stem cell in a Petri dish all by
itself and it would divide every 10 to
12 hours so it'd be 2 4 8 16 cells 32
cells after about two weeks I have
thousands of cells in the petri dish but
what was unique they were all
genetically identical but then I did the
experiment the experiment was to take
some cells out of the dish and put them
into a separate dish with a different
environment okay and so the environment
is a culture medium but the culture
medium to cells is like the world that
we live in it's got the air the water
the food all the things in it so I take
the cells out of my stem cell dish put
them in a separate dish with a different
environment and the cells form muscle
but then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells in it
took some cells out put them in a
different environment and they form bone
and then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells and put
them in a third petri dish with a
different environment and they form fat
cells and there I was confronted with
this reality all the cells are
genetically identical but they had
different fade fat muscle bone I say
simple question what controls the fate
of cells and the answer is the
environment it was the only thing that
was different because they were all
genetically identical so I started to
really say oh my goodness here I am
teaching genes control life to the
medical students and yet the cells were
revealing to me that hey they all had
the same genes but it was the
environment that I put them in and so
the environment controlled their life
and a very simple experiment that is
very profound for us today is if I took
my dish with plastic petri dish with
cells in it and moved it from a healthy
environment to a less and healthy
environment the cells get sick and if I
were a doctor of cells I you might say
well what kind of drugs would you give
these cells and it turns out no you
don't give the cells any drugs you just
take the dish from the bad environment
put it back into a good environment and
the cells will innately naturally come
back to health again I was looking for
relationships I kept failing at them
okay I end up in the Caribbean teaching
at a medical school
the universe throws this into my lap the
perfect pickup line in the whole world
is sort of like hey if you're not doing
anything you want to come and stay in my
villa in the Caribbean and hang out I
have a villa on the beach and I got my
own place and uh blah blah blah and I
still wasn't able to find anybody but I
kept looking because I said I need a
relationship I need a relationship so I
meet this woman who comes off of some
yacht and she's you know got a future
that's like she'll do what she wants and
I thought well if you're not doing
anything why don't you uh you want to
come and stay with me and my Villa on
this beautiful Island
looked at me and she looked at me and
then she said I can't be with you and I
sort of like stop for a moment and she
looked at me and she said you're too
needy
it hit me I said oh my God what am I
looking for a relationship why because
you're not happy so if you're looking
for a relationship because you're not
happy then you're depending on that
relationship to make you happy so that's
not a nice relationship it's
codependency if I give you this place to
stay you will make me happy that's a
trade you know it's like yes and after
she said that I was stunned for a moment
I can't be with you you're too needy she
said and I was stuck and then all of a
sudden I said Thank you thank you very
much it was sort of a slap in the face
right the blessing in disguise right it
totally was it was like wake up and I
walked away from that and I looked at my
life and said you got this most amazing
job you teach a couple days a week you
live in the Caribbean you've got a villa
you got money in your pocket it because
you get paid and there's nothing to buy
in the Caribbean anyways I got I say
you're healthy you got money you got a
great place to live you have the most
wonderful job I go you can't be happy
with that that's what I said to myself
I said how can I you know I'm looking
for this person to make me happy I said
oh no first I make me happy yeah and
then when I make me happy
that changed and it did what happened is
I stopped bitching and started to enjoy
look don't you love where you live yeah
I love where I live do you love Lucia oh
I love the sea you like it oh I love my
job and all the time I started focusing
on hey these are things I love and guess
what
I didn't need anybody that's when you
created abundance and that's when people
became attracted to you right 100
because once I didn't need them I wasn't
like yeah come here I was like ass I
don't care how it works and they showed
up they showed up because I did not need
that was the word because need puts
pressure on that other person that they
have to provide and then they didn't
have to provide it was like hey let me
hang out with you I don't have to
provide anything I could just be me I go
yeah you'll be you I'd be me we have a
great time
and that was the beginning of
reprogramming a need for a relationship
until I was happy with myself and until
that hat once I was happy with myself
and I didn't need a relationship you
should have seen how many opportunities
showed up that were never there in my
life before because the need part pushed
them away the science that says there
are two minds that are operating at the
same time one is called the conscious
mind or one is called the subconscious
mind I say What's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are in that conscious mind and
perceiving the world I say what about
the subconscious mind it's not a
creative mind the subconscious mind is
habits things that you've learned and
you experienced in your life and they
become habits so uh the subconscious
mind is not thinking creating a
subconscious mind push the button play
the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh I wish I had this and
I desire that and these are the things I
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science is recognize
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
I go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing
psychologists will tell us 70 percent or
more of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you have and then to
conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant
because when you stay conscious keep
your mind present you are the creator of
your life and when people are in
mindfulness they manifest their wishes
their desires and their happiness so for
all of us it's sort of a wake-up call
you think you're running your life with
your wishes and desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
for me one of the most personally
exciting things that happened to my life
was to recognize that I was not a victim
a victim of my genes or a victim of my
society that I actually am a creator of
my life and once understanding that
nature and expressing that creativity I
profoundly changed my life from being a
victim to being a master of my creation
and today I have such a wonderful life
that it actually has no comparison to
the first 40 years of my life where I
lived under the pro programming that I
received as a child today I've created
such a joyous wonderful life that I look
forward every day to waking up to have
another day on this beautiful planet
another major assumption is that we're
equivalent to genetic automatons we have
genes they control us we don't control
the genes and therefore we're sort of
like victims of our heredity you got
cancer running in your family say oh my
goodness I'm going to get the cancer I
got the genes or Alzheimer's or diabetes
whatever this is completely false
because it turns out genes control
nothing it's really the environment that
is controlling the genes and more
importantly our perception of the
environment how we see the world what we
think about the world is adjusting our
genetics so we find out disease one
percent of disease is connected to
genetics ninety percent or more of
diseases connected to how we live in the
world because how we live in the world
is altering or affecting our genetic
activity so what we know and and what we
believe is changing our reality
constantly right because the new
scientists called epigenetics and what
it means is this our beliefs and how we
see the world we change our genetics so
rather than being victims which we have
believed all the way up to now we are
the Masters we change our genetics just
by how we respond to the world so we can
change our responses which means then we
can change our genetics so we're not
victims a very important part of our
understanding about life is that it's
our perception of Life which actually
means our beliefs about life so the
significance is if you're going to plan
your life and you're going to make
perceptions the programmer of your life
well then the best thing you can do is
perceive of the life that you would wish
and desire because those thoughts will
be translated by biology into the
expression of your cells and your
genetics and you will manifest your
wishes and your desires and that's what
the new biology is all about all you
need is love and and we really have to
recognize that love is a vibration it's
not a physical thing it's a feeling that
people get and it's it's a Harmony and
this is what love is versus fear love is
Harmony music it all comes together
beautifully fear is noise disharmony and
a Breaking of the vibrational Harmony
and so really it's like bring it back
together again and bring everything back
into harmony the the planet the
environment ourselves our community of
humanity and and when it is in harmony
it is love
and so that's the message that that was
really brought from this Center uh
through the Beatles
and and given to the world
All You Need Is Love
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
about the law of attraction Secrets
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there then I'm gonna
feel so great now that well then they're
back to the program waiting for it to
happen for them to feel the emotion
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no